I know I am wearing a new bronzer I like
it too and I got my hair cut an inch
shorter which is what they are cut is my
definition my reaction to cutting my
hair short is I think the same reaction
I would have if I woke up with a penis I
just keep touching it so I went on
tumblr to ask you guys what kind of
videos did you want to see this week
very old-school of me very brain-dead of
me and a lot of you guys one decision of
consciousness video which I wanted to
shoot anyway so this works out really
well if you guys don't know it's true
because this video is where I just
talked to you in a stream of
consciousness type of way it's
summertime you know what that means how
to work on those dance moves also a lot
of you guys wanted me to react to Taylor
Swift's bad blood music video and here's
my reaction it's over talked about one
long subtweet am i right Katy Perry from
what I've heard about the relationship
you have with Taylor Swift because I'm
short here does that mean I should wear
hats perhaps a short hair thing yes
oh no what a mess Wow what's happening
with you guys it is May it's gonna be
June so your calendar app broke you're
welcome Wow
I made Bruce kepta today because when I
have so many things to do I decide that
things like making bruschetta are more
important than the important things that
I have to do next how I waste my time
they make coke zero cherry flavor did
you know that
get over yourself you
like a new wiener on my head just keep
touching it congratulations if you
graduate it if you didn't
congratulations on having a non
significant moment in time at the
current moment but this at the kids
section of target why was it there
children will never appreciate how
Pinterest this is a lot of you also
wanted a video with my dog goose and
morning routine videos are also very
popular right now so I thought that I'm
which are you guys my dog's morning
routine very powerful these aren't real
Wow look at that that looks very trying
here's the thing I do I think Taylor
Swift is probably a cool person and I
think we will get along Wow a huge
revelation just now ah I just remembered
that I have gummy vitamins I shouldn't
be even oh and now I also just remember
that I am at all band-aids don't fix
bullet holes someone went to med school
every wondering what it would be like to
have giant cotton balls hanging in one
of your rooms you're about to find out
oh you gotta like do more than one step
sorry guys I have better things to do
now we've got bad blood wow this has
been really fun you guys I hope that you
enjoyed this tree of consciousness blog
is there anything going on in your life
that is significant Oh
broke me break the internet I did it
it's broken
I don't know if you haven't already make
sure you buy your tickets for the no
filter comedy show tour with myself and
mamrie Hart and Hannah Hart there are
tickets left
in Chicago San Francisco and Seattle so
go check them out anything mighty I
don't you're lucky